[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on est en direct on est
avec vous c'est figaro live et on attend
vos points de vue faut-il vraiment une
nouvelle loi pour encadrer
l'irresponsabilité pénale c'est la
question qu'on se pose alors que
l'émotion est toujours vive autour du
nom procès de l'assassin de sarah halimi
on en débat ce soir avec dominique
reynié bonsoir 2000 soir professeur à
sciences po et directeur général de la
fondapol on signale la dernière une des
dernières études
la fondapol sur l'europe et les
populismes et avec nous comme chaque
mardi quasiment avec sea breeze et
directeur des rédactions du figaro
bonsoir à bord
l'autre sujet qui a fait polémique et on
en parle également dans le figaro en
tout cas dans l'édition de ceux de
l'édition print de ce mardi c'est la
nouvelle campagne d'affichage d'europe
écologie les verts qui appellent les
jeunes vous savez aller voter pour les
prochaines régionales pour ne pas
laisser les boumeurs les chasseurs ou
alain finkielkraut voter julien bayou le
leader d'europe écologie les verts a
plaidé l'erreur est ce que vous croyez à
cette thèse vous nous le dites on en
débat mais d'abord donc une question
faut-il revoir la loi sur
l'irresponsabilité pénale
c'est la question qu'on me pose encore
sur twitter cet après midi hier vous
avez répondu nombreux sur le site du
figaro déjà à cette question plus de
100000 et à plus de 90% où vous avez
répondu oui il faut modifier la loi elle
va être modifiée eric dupond moretti l'a
annoncé il confirmait ans l'a déjà les
propos tenus à la salle par la
présidente de la commission des lois à
l'assemblée
débutés en marche idéal brawn ou privés
la balle est dans notre camp le
président de la république a souhaité
également que le législateur se saisisse
de cette question
donc je crois que maintenant à nous
législateurs justement de travailler
la question donc juridique du
discernement et je dirais même plus loin
moi ce que je souhaite faire c'est au
sein de la commission des lois que j'ai
l'honneur de présider je proposerai
amédée les députés qui en sont membres
que l'on travaille d'une part sur la
question du discernement mais d'autre
part sur la question aussi de la
procédure alors dans le figaro
aujourd'hui paul gonzalez révèle que en
2018 la cour de cassation
celle là même qui a dit qu'il ne
pourriez pas avoir de procès dans le
meurtre de sarah leamy la cour de
cassation avait maintenu le procès d'un
meurtrier qui plaidé l'irresponsabilité
pour avoir consommé des produits
stupéfiants
exactement le même cas que le meurtrier
de sara lee me à l'époque la même cour
sur la base du même article du code
pénal l'article 122-1 avait non
seulement rejeté la demande du meurtrier
mais en plus avaient considéré que la
prise des stupéfiants était une
circonstance aggravante jouer cette
affaire pour poser la question est ce
que dans ces conditions est ce que le
problème c'est la loi est ce que c'est
pas plutôt les juges
alexis déjà il faut bien enfin dans
cette affaire et la question des faits
de l'espèce donc c'est pas de choses
abominables qui est arrivé à sare halimi
et puis la question des principes de
droit et il faut comme voie relie les
deux choses d'abord la spec de
l'événement sara lee mais il faut bien
voir que se concentre sur cette atroce
agressions dont ksar halimi français de
confession juive et tranquillement dans
son appartement un gars cab kabylie
traoré entre par la fenêtre la massacre
absolument pendant une heure la tabasse
la torture bonheur finissent par la
jetée par la fenêtre tout ça aux cris d'
allah akbar en récitant des sourates du
coran et elle meurt en tombant par la
fenêtre et donc la question et on
découvre que ce gars avaient été
bourrées de cannabis da cannabis très
fort et donc se pose la question de s
qui est ce que il est responsable de
l'acte absolument atroces qu'il a commis
si on se remet dans le contexte est il
compte dans cette affaire le conteste on
est en 2010 est en avant le premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle et on se
rend compte que cette affaire sarr
halimi pendant des jours et des jours on
ne veut pas en parler et sans doute que
c'est lié au contexte de l'élection
présidentielle que on veut yahia mari me
plaît
et montrer que un homme noir musulman a
agressé à mort une femme de confession
juive
c'est quelque chose qui dérangeait on ne
veut pas en parler et avant même le
jugement de la cour de cassation etc
il ya d'abord la question de
l'instruction qui fait que pendant des
jours et des mois on ne veut pas
reconnaître le caractère antisémite de
cette de cette agression je me souviens
à l'époque au figaro on publie une
tribune semble de personnalités
finkielkraut onfray julliard badinter
gauche et elisabeth badinter on est un
peu seul à l'époque parce que c'est
quelque chose dont on n'a pas parlé et
nous ont dit mais c'est quand même
bizarre pourquoi est-ce qu'on veut pas
en parler
pourquoi est-ce qu'on veut pas
reconnaître que c'est un meurtre
antisémite et pendant des semaines le
juge si on voudra pas reconnaître que
c'est assez vite ne voudra pas peu
organiser une reconstitution pour des
raisons qu'on ignore enfin ce qui dans
une manière de l'instruction est un peu
original et à la fin des fins le
caractère antisémite de l'agression sera
reconnue mais la chambre d'accusation
sur la foi des rapports d'experts dira
les experts après avoir un peu hésité
nous disent que le le le
le discernement de cobly traoré était
aboli parce qu'elle est pris trop de
cannabis donc si son discernement était
aboli
c'est la loi ça si le discernement était
absolument aboulie on ne peut pas le
juger est donc ce gala n'est pas jugée
va en hôpital psychiatrique
on nous dit qu'il sera surveillé mais
enfin psychiatrie qui finira un jour par
en sortir
évidemment la famille de ce rallye me et
bien au delà et la communauté juive et
bien au delà et les français disent mais
c'est effrayant comme un assassinat
meurtre comme celui-là ne soient pas
jugés donc voilà le le tabloïd où se
pose la question de est-ce qu'il faut
revoir la loi pour pour que ce genre de
cas ne se reproduise pas mais je veux
pas monopoliser la parole c'est un sujet
dramatique ça c'est certain
kiki fait fond il faut le rappeler sur
une constante puce et de l'antisémitisme
en france et d'un antisémitisme et là ça
pour tous nos compatriotes musulmans qui
vivent une vie paisible
c'est toujours extrêmement désagréable
d'entendre ça mais c'est isolement est
très très très clair nous on a documenté
ça la fondation dans des travaux qu'on a
fait d'ailleurs à l'échelle européenne
c'est tout à fait net donc il ya une en
arrière fond qui est un problème
documenté extrêmement préoccupant et qui
nous dit sur qui nous renseigne sur une
évolution de la société mais je crois
que plus personne n'est surpris
d'entendre ça mais enfin même temps
fondé quand même qu'on trouve des
réponses à ce à ce problème qui devient
extrêmement préoccupant et puis ensuite
un aspect qui est faux il ya un sujet
très technique dans cette affaire je
n'ai pas la compétence pour ma part dans
ce domaine qui est le droit pénal
il ya un aspect technique qui complexent
donc il faudrait en parler en ayant des
informations ou une compétence que je
n'ai pas je m'étonne par contre qu'il
n'y ait pas eu une explication une sorte
de comptes-rendus peut-être d'en quête
sans accabler les juges meco d'ailleurs
sur l'ensemble du processus comment ça
c'est passé tout ça y compris c'est à
dire à l'instant mais y compris pourquoi
la police n'est pas intervenue
il manque des éléments d'information
dans cette affaire tout est un peu
trouble non pas qu'il y ait des choses
cachées mais on ne sait pas très bien
comment ça s'est passé
depuis l'appel au secours jusqu'à cette
absence de perquisition qui a peut-être
ces deux reconstitutions pardon qui a
peut-être ces raisons qui a sans doute
ses raisons mais elles ne sont pas
donnés et puis re dire aussi que nous
sommes devant une situation extrêmement
impressionnante parce que il ne faudrait
pas non plus de l'autre côté que la loi
supprime
cette clause qui veut que les personnes
qui ont qui n'ont pas leur raison sont
pas responsables donc c'est très fragile
tout ça il faut pas qu'on tombe de cela
oui c'est en fait c'est très très
difficile d'établir qu'est ce que dit la
loi le dit que si le discernement de
quelqu'un est aboli il n'est pas
responsable mais que si son discernement
était altéré
elle est responsable alors où est la
frontière entre un discernement aboli
par une maladie psychique ou par un
trouble psychique qui lui-même veut être
la conséquence de prise de stupéfiants
pascal leu leu comme s'il n'y a pas de
maladies psychiques qui n'est pas
schizophrène mais il a nous dit-on nous
disent les experts une bouffée délirante
qui elle même est occasionnée pour la
prise de stupéfiants
donc si cette bouffée délirante abouti à
l'abolition totale de son discernement
il est irresponsable si ça n'aboutit
qu'à une abolition partielle de son
décernement il est partiellement
responsable et donc là les experts après
avoir hésité sa finiront par dire que
globalement il considère qu'il est
irresponsable et la coue la chambre
d'accusation qui décident de sortie à
procès ou non
diba donc puisqu'il était responsable on
le juge pas et tous ces points dont vous
parlez donc vous dites c'est vrai qu'ils
sont encore pas très claires ne le
saurai et éclaircissent s'il y avait eu
problème évidemment sur et donc c'est un
problème qui dépasse le cas halimi parce
que ce après quoi ceux qui se posent de
plus en plus parce qu'on se rend compte
ce que je vais vous notamment autour des
affaires de terrorisme de plus en plus
on l'entend à c'est un déséquilibré à
c'était un dingue à il n'était pas bien
normal même le gars de rambouillet alors
nous ne dit plus trop maintenant
mais rappelez-vous le papier de libé qui
nous dit avant de rentrer en tunisie il
n'était pas très bien mais j'avais pas
seulement libérée il ya une certaine et
risation oui et est donc si on entre là
dedans on finira par faire à chaque fois
va se poser la question de s que son
discernement était aboli est-ce qu'il
est dingue un peu dingue à moitié d'agde
et donc donc tout un tas de questions de
réforme de sa se pose sans pour autant
effectivement revenir sur un principe de
droit et de bon sens que si quelqu'un
est absolument fou il n'est pas
responsable de ce qui fait donc il faut
trouver la juste balance
peut-être que ça peut être alors il y
avait pas mal de propositions un qui va
peut-être que ça peut être comme
le dit alors une députée dont j'ai
oublié mon départ je voulais ouais c'est
ça exactement leurs fidèles elle dit que
si le comportement est lié à une prise
volontaire de stupéfiants donc en gros
on a causé soi même les conditions là à
ce moment là il faudrait dire que c'est
peu c'est à ce moment là on redevient
était large je suis puisque après tout
on a on n'était pas pris la
responsabilité d'aso dire ça mais c'est
vrai que c'est un peu paradoxal si vous
êtes bourrés au volant de la voiture ou
que vous avez fumé et que vous écraser
quelqu'un c'est une circonstance
aggravante
et là on pense vous assassinez quelques
huées quelqu'un mais que vous êtes vous
êtes vous avez tellement bu ou tellement
fumée que vous avez perdu quasiment
connaissance c'est une circonstance
aggravante c'est une circonstance
atténuante c'est vrai que c'est un peu
compliqué à expliquer ce qui je peux
juste a ajouté qu'il faudrait là aussi
creusé parce qu'il ya des formes de
fanatisme qui sont en elles-mêmes des
altérations de la raison et de la
volonté
et donc c'est comme si on ouvrait le
champ vers une exonération des meurtres
des comportements violents qui sont
déclenchées sinon inspiré par une forme
de passion religieuse ou politique
il ya quelque chose qui n'est pas
possible il faut effectivement
passionnément normal quand on se lance
dans l'assassinât de massoud dans un
attentat à la bombe
il ya bien mais pour autant on est quand
même responsable sinon on épuise en fait
ce qui est posée quand même à travers
ces affaires là est-ce que vous soulevez
également alexis c'est avec sur les
affaires théorie c'est la question de la
responsabilité qui est quand même un
débat on est quand même plus tellement
loin de la culture de l'excusé
absolument absolument c'est enfin c'est
d'autant plus que d'autant plus que nous
sommes dans les sociétés notamment par
la numérisation de l'espace public les
plateformes sur lesquelles on le sait ya
des effets c'est complètement documenté
il ya des effets de radicalisation de
polarisation qui sont liés au mécanisme
n'a pas le développer ici c'est pas le
sujet mais ça on sait que ça marche
c'est observer et donc nous serons de
plus en plus souvent confrontés à ces
formes d'isolement dans ma bulle de
radicalisation et puis je sors et au
contact de l'extérieur
j'ai accompli un geste terrible mais je
peux dire immofonds mon discernement
était altéré avec un étonnant si on y
réfléchit bien chassé croisé depuis 40
ans entre la gauche et la droite sur
sept ce rapport à la folie rappelez-vous
michel foucault il n'y a pas de fous la
folie est une invention de la société
une invention répressives pour isoler et
mettre hors d'état de nuire les déviants
les gens qui n'entrent pas dans les
normes gt mais la folie est une
invention social new deal à la gauche
des haines des années 70 70 à l'époque
la droite di mascio du golf où il faut
les enfermer et aujourd'hui c'est
intéressant ce qu'il ya comme une espèce
de chassé croisé où la gauche qui parle
de tout cas les partisans de l'ex cus
pénale qui sont pas tous à gauche est
passée par toute la gauche nous disent
ah bah oui mais si il ya des fous et
cela avant bâle cas ils sont pas
responsables et la droite dit non non
non ils sont pas font quand même six ans
tué il faut les il faut les juger
c'est intéressant comme chassé-croisé
idéologique j'en ai fini en évoquant une
autre solution qui évoqué par françois
bayrou qui n'est pas un monstre de
répression de sanguinaires ni
totalitaire qui lui s'appuie sur un
événement qui avait lieu à pau il ya
quelques années en 2004 ou un gave et
avait décapité de personnes ce gars là
n'a pas été jugé parce qu'il était fou
et donc bayrou dit d'accord on peut pas
juger les fous mais ne pourrait-on pas
juger le point de savoir si quelqu'un
est fou ce qui n'est pas exactement la
même chose c'était qu'aujourd'hui qui
décide si quelqu'un vous ce sont des
espèces désespère 6 4 en dehors de toute
procédure de délibération et de
transparence s'il y avait une audience
ont déjà on mettait sur la table le
point de savoir si untel untel est l es
fou pas fou on peut faire intervenir les
psychiatres enfin juge déciderait ou un
jury populaire se sent qu'on est et au
moins ce point là serait purger et après
s'il est fou on ne juge pas s'il est pas
fou on le juge c'est aussi ça peut être
aussi une évolution législative qui
proposait par bayrou et par karoutchi au
sénat
la consommation de drogue est une
circonstance aggravante estime nicole
sébastien nous dit certaines personnes
sont véritablement irresponsable compte
tenu de leur état psychique et de leur
conscience atteinte il vous faut il vaut
mieux connaître la vraie
irresponsabilité
la vraie il reste encore être la vraie
irresponsabilité nadine indique que
faute de places dans des structures
adaptées un nombre considérable de fous
se trouve en liberté sera intéressant
vérifier à chaque difficulté
d'application de la loire on veut la
refaire nous dit serge et puis en plus
il y aura des cas spécifiques dans la
loi plus graves difficultés
la loi est déjà suffisante sans savoir
si la loi est déjà suffisante est-ce que
ce que soulève cette internaute et pas
un autre
un autre problème encore une fois je
repose l'information que nous révèle
paul gonzalez ce matin la même fin la
cour de cassation à partir des mêmes
faits et type de faits et départir de
même type de loi à deux interprétations
des interprétations différentes
je veux pas monopoliser mais la
colocation ne se prononce pas sur les
faits elle se prononce sur le droit donc
elle dit en fonction de ce que les
experts ont dit à la chambre
d'accusation la chute de l'action était
fondée ou pas fondé à dire que le gars
est responsable ou presque ne dit pas il
est responsable par l'ac milan serrières
elle n'a pas vu le type l'apa donc ce
n'est pas la question
elle dit juste on a les rapports des
experts donc en droit la queue donc en
fait si la cour de si la chambre
d'accusation avait décidé par exemple
qu'il était responsable
la cour de cassation qui aurait pu aussi
bien dire que c'était fondé en droit
puisqu'elle ne le juge pas les faits dit
juste et elle a vu les rapports
d'experts les à la chambre d'accusation
les a regardés on a déduit qu'il était
responsable
donc il est responsable voilà deux qui
reçoivent donc ils responsables elle a
pas eu d'effet la cour de cassation
ça reste un problème de fond est très
difficile à résoudre mais une décision
de justice doit tout de même être
intelligible par la société c'est que
c'est très troublant est très
préoccupant que sur sur deux deux cas
qui a reste très proche il ya deux
décisions qui soient apparemment aussi
divergentes
et même si dans le détail deux
de la décision on peut trouver des
justifications et ça c'est respectable
bien sûr il faudrait arriver tout de
même à des formes dénoncé qui rendent
compréhensible ce type de décision par
la société parce que sinon c'est un 17
on va avoir un discours en petit justice
anti magistrature et vous avoir un
discours de vengeance et de justice
expéditive ça le meilleur moyen de
purger de ça c'est l'audience publique
ça que les choses se passent sous le
regard des français et on pourrait
imaginer une espèce d'audience de une
exception d'irresponsabilité avant
l'avant le jugement comme pour dire fou
pas fou puis après on met rien que le
fait de délibéré de ça de le faire juger
comme ça permettrait de mettre sur la
table ça manque d'éléments qui
aujourd'hui nous sont totalement
inconnues on n'a même pas les rapports
d'experts personne ne les a vus donc on
ne sait pas diverger d'ailleurs et qui
en plus des vergers moi je retiens j'ai
de la conversation si vous me permettez
l'argument qui veut que vous avez non
c'est selon lequel quelqu'un qui prend
volontairement qu'il peut ne pas le
faire une substance qui altère son
jugement paraît quand même pouvoir être
considéré comme ayant engagé sa
responsabilité de préméditation bien
nous dit donc qu'il est favorable à une
nouvelle loi puisqu'il nous dit parce
que tous les personnes accro au cannabis
deviendront irresponsable double b nous
dit a priori pour tuer faut être dingue
donc aucun meurtrier en prison et
nathalie nous disent nous dit être sous
l'emprise de stupéfiants ne doit pas
être un motif pour disculper l'auteur de
crimes quel qu'il soit et
voilà daniel nous disait sur twitter
avant le début de cette émission il est
interdit de tuer et la prise de
stupéfiants est prohibé tout est dit en
tous les cas on posait reposer la
question sur twitter faut-il revoir la
loi sur les responsabilités pénales et
vous répondez majeur massivement oui à
83 % moins fortement que sur le site du
figaro on était à 90% il ya une autre
question qu'on vous pose aujourd'hui est
ce que vous allez voter pour les
régionales dominique vous allez voter
oui vous n'êtes pas candidat cette fois
encore il a cette fois ci mais je vais
voter chez moi dans l'aveyron à
onet-le-château
bon comme d'habitude alexis vous de
voter voir aussi par procuration alors
la direction d'europe écologie les verts
aussi et pour aller faire voter les plus
jeunes
elle n'a pas hésité à faire ces visuels
que l'on va voir dans les collimateurs
vous le voyez les boumeurs eric zemmour
les fachos les chasseurs gérald hamas
pas tous les mêmes et alors françois
bayrou n'y est pas mais il est en colère
on écoute mène toujours les gens à
l'heure je disais couleur de peau
religion est là à leur âge à leurs
opinions
plus personne n'est regardé comme un
citoyen
cette campagne elle dit on regarde pas
les gens comme des citoyens on les
regarde comme appartenant à une
catégorie une communauté et que c'est la
catégorie et la communauté qui font le
vote devant le devant le tollé en tout
cas les responsables d'europe écologie
les verts sont montés au créneau à
julien bayou apprête à plaider l'erreur
voici en tout cas la ligne de défense
tenue par les promoteurs de la campagne
notamment le communiqué le communicant
pardon il concerne invités de point de
vue arnaud chant premier de trégunc
alors faites c'est une campagne qui
cherche à mobiliser les non inscrits les
jeunes qui sont pas inscrits on a voulu
montrer un peu ce qui était anti écolo
des intellectuels les productivistes et
autres et puis y avait une autre
compagne qui était prévu pour dire il ya
une fracture générationnelle sur les
inscriptions n'y avait pas de problème
si c'était pris de façon isolée et qu'on
disait il ya une fracture
générationnelle sur les inscrits sur les
listes électorales c'est ça que vous
voulez dire mais de mélanger les deux
c'est à dire ceux qui sont anti écolos
et les baby boomer qui sont des gens qui
votent plus que les plus jeunes
là il ya une confusion et c'est devenu
blessant à ce moment là alors c'est
devenu besson n'a pas voulu décliner a
pas de mode exclusif a dit est ce que on
peut blé on peut plaider la thèse de
l'erreur quand on entend ça comme le feu
julien bayou bah c'est pire qu'une heure
c'est une faute
c'est évidemment pas une heure de la
part des gens qui l'ont conçu ils ont
conçu sciemment après c'est une erreur
en ce sens que ça se retourne contre les
verts parce que c'est indigne
légitimement les gens voient alors on
savait que les verts et mais pas les
sapins de noël on savait qu'ils aimaient
pas les avions parce qu'il faut
interdire normalement les rêves
d'enfants
on savait que j'aimais pas les bateaux à
voile maintenant il n'aime pas les gens
qui ont fait qu'en plus de 50 ans parce
qu'en gros à boomer c'est quoi c'est
plus de 50 ans même 40 ans à partir de
commencer donc c'est quand même
effrayant dominique la question quand on
regarde les résultats des derniers
scrutins ils sont en tête chez les 18 24
ans et 25 30 et 34 ans quand ces
catégories vote
c'est imparable on comprend dans ces
conditions de reprise ont fait cette
campagne
ben moi je ne comprends pas sinon que
les verts depuis quelque temps ont perdu
tout contact avec
la réalité de la société telle qu'elle
est et je pense que c'est à savoir ça va
en s'aggravant
je pense qu'ils ne comprennent rien à ce
qu'est le pays et à ce qui est en train
de devenir et en plus en ce moment tout
particulièrement donc c'est une faute
politique au sens où ils ont bien mais
la stratégie qui donne ces affiches
ça se retourne contre eux mais c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'ils sont pas
excusés parce qu'il sentait bien que la
faute vient d'eux donc il croyait bien
faire pendant leurs intérêts ils les
desservent
mais en réalité
moi je mets en garde depuis longtemps
contre des effets déformant il y à une
partie de la jeunesse qui affirme dans
les enquêtes d'opinion
un attachement militants à la
décroissance et à la cause
environnementaliste et qui sont souvent
des enfants issus des catégories aisées
et supérieur ils vont très peu voté mais
la jeunesse dans sa grande généralité
soit elle ne vote pas soit elle vote
front faut le rappeler pour le
rassemblement national et pour marine le
pen oui mais aux élections européennes
de 2009 par exemple les dernières
élections 1700 cette jeunesse qui est
allé voter n'a voté dans sa non mais là
ça m'a jamais elle est au nord 75 % ne
se sont pas allés voter chez les jeunes
même qu'à ceux qui sont allés voir et je
dis mais c'est à dire que la voilà vous
prenez les 5%
vous prenez ce qui reste d'un petit
électriques dans les grands centres je
rappelle qu'au niveau national
europe ecologie les verts aux
municipales a fait 3,2 pour cent ils ont
fait si bons scores dans six mais là où
il fallait
les six métropoles quand vous prenez
tous les électeurs à droite gauche tous
les acteurs ça fait 12 % des inscrits là
dedans il ya dans six villes
une petite majorité sur une grande
abstention massive qui prend la ville et
on divague vers bon moi je veux pas
revenir là dessus parce que ça a été
beaucoup dire en tout cas moi je vais
beaucoup dit mais mais mais c'est un on
va voir lacombe avant la correction va
être intéressant je veux dire au sens
statistique
comment les choses se recaler la gloire
qui sont me semble et il le sera
d'autant plus brutale qui font tout pour
qu'elles le soient c'est à dire que
malgré tout mme ils sont en train de
gâcher une chance historique qui est la
leur il
ils servent sur un thème
extraordinairement populaire enfin la
défense de l'environnement le
réchauffement climatique le seuil
pourrait en faire leur sort d'un vrai
succès à condition de ne pas tomber dans
la dinguerie de sectarisme tout propos
parce que le choix des gens qui choisit
qui des têtes de turcs qui se choisit
c'est quand même très intéressant alors
ils choisissent les chasseurs pour dire
à voix les écologistes aime pas les
chasseurs ça peut discuter je sais
reconnaître quand même au moins autant
la nature comme plein d'écologistes mais
bon ça on peut comprendre et de toujours
mais quand ils disent en darmana est un
méchant
quel rapport est ce que d'armagnac
contre l'environnement je connais pas
une conviction de dammam je pense pas du
tout simplement pourquoi je suis là
parce qu'ils représentent
à l'intérieur ce qui représente la
police mais en quoi est ce que c'est de
défendre l'environnement qu'être contre
la police quand ils veulent et
finkielkraut finkielkraut et pas du tout
contre eux et heureusement c'est un des
premiers à défendre la cause animale
rappelez vous ces développements sur la
vache la vache qui danse dans les gens
et c'est donc ils défendent la nature et
l'écologie
et ça le rend il herrera qui défend
l'enracinement et défendre la nation il
défend la tradition donc c'est ça qui
est donc c'est là dessus qu'ils vont
l'attaquer
vous savez que vous êtes bien bon car
oui et alors et après on peut aussi
retrouver d'autres d'autres raisons plus
trouble et quand ils vont attaquer quand
ils les boumeurs les gens les plus de 50
ans les il n'est plus de plus de 50 ans
sont pas tous mais pourquoi ils vont les
chercher parce que derrière leur teneur
dans leurs constructions mentales il
yal'idée on va construire un monde
nouveau
en éradiquant l'humanité ancien qui donc
les vieux en s'appuyant sur des jeunes
mais en plus c'est pas vrai c'est que
les jeunes que votre bourreau mais vous
voyez une espèce de sectarisme dengue
qui sont en train de développer en 2002
gâché une bonne idée vous dites c'est
les vieux qui veut te vient en tout cas
ce grand nombre d'éditeurs c'est là que
votre pas plutôt pour la république en
marche pas non mais il ya de toute façon
vous aucun parti n'a le monopole d'une
catégorie comme ça mais les fellahs
quand on fait les calculs mais regardez
regardez même les la structure des
parties d'europe écologie les verts qui
est aux commandes
cd bonheur je suis désolé voit partout à
peut-être pas julien bayou mais
franchement c'est plutôt cette
génération là non ce qui est ce qu'il
faut surtout quoi il faut insister je
pense le problème avec europe ecologie
les verts c'est pas le problème avec
l'écologie politique c'est le problème
des roms d'europe écologie les verts
c'est que fondamentalement en réalité
c'est une gauche anticapitaliste qui n'a
pas beaucoup d'intérêt pour l'écologie
en réalité et qui cherche à travers
cette thématique à poursuivre son combat
contre l'économie de marché que fonds
qui a été perdu avec l'effondrement du
communisme
donc c'est l'anti capitalisme quand le
mur de berlin est tombé c'est ça europe
ecologie les verts
ils ne sont pas sincères sur
l'environnement il voit là un outil pour
poursuivre cette lutte
et s'il voulait amener une majorité en
effet derrière eux ils ne proposerait
pas un ne s'opposerait pas au
productivisme comme on l'a entendu dans
l'interview il s'opposerait à la
décroissance qu'il serait pour une
croissance verte pour une croissance
décarbonés il serait pour le nucléaire
du coup pour les biotechnologies qui
permettent de protéger la biodiversité
de réduire les intrants et d'avoir une
agriculture performante
il serait pour une croissance compatible
avec l'environnement les français
veulent du pouvoir d'achat et ils
veulent de la consommation il aurait
avec eux des majorités là c'est un
projet idéologique qui est faux qui
parasitent le thème et
environnementalistes et le contraste
d'ailleurs avec les verts allemands et
dieu sait qu'ils ont été radicaux et de
c'est qu'ils ont été idéologie d'état
écoutent aujourd'hui frappant alors
généralement ressentis nucléaire mais
pour le reste ils sont chers de 6 5 ou 6
régions avec les cd où ils sont même
devant je n'oserais jose 2 ou sur des
thèses écologistes ils ne sont même plus
anti ogm et voilà donc en gros il
comment ils ont créé va-t-en guerre
oui en plus et sans ils sont militarise
si l'on m'accorde l'économie marché sont
pas contre la police nous les nôtres
effectivement c'est exactement ce que
des amis c'est à dire qu'ils sont contre
les flics contre contre la nation contre
la patrie que parce que chine qui voit
là c'est mal ses racines mans et puis et
puis contre les vieux parce qu'il faut
faire
on va refaire la révolution avec une
humanité nouvelle c'est quand même
quelque chose d un espèce de
deux projets qui a fait qu'ici on le
pousse à bout et eux mêmes selon le
pousse au bout fait froid dans le dos
enfin quand on dit on va changer les
rêves des enfants ont dis pas ça par
hasard ça vient de quelque part l'idée
de dire on va changer les règles devant
quelque elle être normal on vous suit
dire et ça nous va retirer sa des rêves
des enfants
ça veut dire table rase on va refaire ce
monde là n'oublie pas effectivement
c'est la révolution pas d'autres moyens
c'est la révolution
en utilisant le bras de levier de 2,2 de
l'écologie mais l'écologie n'est pas le
vrai sujet il joue de rajouter que quand
on suit ce dossier de près moi c'est mon
cas europe ecologie les verts par c'est
par ces orateurs y compris yannick jadot
d'ailleurs ce qui est très surprenant et
décevant d'ailleurs régulièrement
utilise des informations qui sont
fausses et les utilisent l'information
qui sont fausses qui sont fausses et
notamment sur la question de l'énergie
sur la question des biotechnologies
c'est un parti qui a pris l'habitude
maintenant d'utiliser des arguments des
faits qui nous sont peut-être d'affecter
ses sept recrues et d'utiliser beaucoup
moi ça me frappe également chacun peut
le leur a observé j'imagine sa manière
d'utiliser des informations anxiogène
avec une forme de jubilation par les
collègues solo j'y vois là absolument
avait des sentiments que vous allez
avoir à répondre et on va vous faire 800
c'est à dire que le monde vous l'avez
dit vous allez voir c'est la catastrophe
vous l'avez voulu vous l'aurez mais
parce que leur engagement n'est pas du
domaine de la raison ces domaines de la
fois c'est un s'estime légitime à
utiliser des arguments pour trouver des
photos des éléments faux parce qu'ils
sont du côté du vrai du juste donc tout
tout vient autorisé par des monceaux bat
pour quelque chose de vrai je ne crois
pas je crois qu'ils sont vraiment dans
la sincérité complète et que c'est une
utile bras 6 heures dans la semaine ils
sont dans la sacem charité quand il
parle d'environnement douala dans une
sincérité relative mais ils sont dans
une sorte de sincérité absolue quand il
quand ils prétendent rebâtir une
humanité sur des bases nouvelles
débarrassé des capitalistes des flics
des bourgeois et des vieux ces salons
lors la société qui va les entraîner
aussi poreux et des enfants parce que
les enfants plus ça pollue ça consomme
et c'est pas bien donc non mais c'est ça
c'est un rêve des murs joly europe
écologie
verts veulent diviser les français vous
n'êtes pas très très indulgent sur
europe écologie les verts dans le chat
en tous les cas vous ne faites pas
partie sur le plateau ouais c'est je
pense que certains candidats auraient
préféré que ce soit cet électorat là à
bordeaux allieront par europe écologie
et les verts veulent diviser les
françaises utilisent la couleur de peau
la religion et maintenant les
générations ce que nous dit général
escape chardons bleus là les verts se
révèle dans toute leur horreur
philippe hervé les traite de petit maire
et micheline ce parti ressemble à une
secte pour les élections ils n'iront pas
très loin dans les votes qu'est ce que
disent les polissons d'âge pour les pour
les prochaines régionales mais ça dépend
ça dépend des régions ça n'est pas une
région mais des chances je ne vois pas
dans quelle région ils ont des chances à
son seul nom
et puis vous voyez toutes les données
que nous avons en termes de sondages
aujourd'hui les place dans une situation
qui est qui ne sera pas même pas celle
de la der des élections européennes où
dans une abstention de 50% il n'avait
pas démérité
un score qui les place en troisième
position et arthur nous dit c'est
vraiment détestable mais ça j'aime bien
l'idéologie manichéenne manichéenne
d'europe écologie les verts on vous
posez donc la question
europe écologie les verts at il fait une
dont il fait une erreur avec ces visuels
de campagne je sais pas si on va voir la
réponse pour tous les cas elle était
vous répondiez oui en majorité oui à 85%
merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve demain même heure même endroit
et vous ne voyez pas de retrouver des
articles dont on a parlé notamment ceux
de paul gonzalez dans l'édition papier
du figaro si vous n'avez pas encore
acheté sinon vous l'avez sur le site
lefigaro.fr a très vite sur figure au
life merci beaucoup